under the watchful eyes of Israeli
soldiers Palestinians living in this
neighborhood are scared of reprisals
after one of the worst attacks on
Israelis in years occupation forces
carried out door-to-door raids in their
assalamud arresting more than 40 people
including the attackers family friends
and Neighbors
they say they're being collectively
punished after 21 year old killed seven
Israelis outside a synagogue on Friday
his family say they've not been allowed
to leave the home the whole building has
uncles cousins and his father we just
saw his father earlier he was allowed to
leave for a few moments but the Israeli
authorities sent him back up we're going
to go and find out more
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu promised Swift action in the
aftermath had his home and that of a 13
year old who carried out another attack
on Saturday have had their home sealed
well we've just been stopped by the
Israeli authorities of getting any
closer to highly alcom's home it's a
six-story home with his extended family
members already living there many of
them are stuck inside they've not been
allowed out by the Israeli authorities
for the last three days some of the kids
behind me are also family members some
of them said that they have been able to
see their mother or father for the last
three days they've been promised that
they will at some point but it's not
clear when and tensions here seem to be
really high
rasa landward is a neighborhood in
Sylvan in occupied East Jerusalem a
flash point for confrontations between
Palestinians and Jewish settlers land
grabs and home demolitions the new
Israeli right-wing government is fast
tracking the destruction of homes of
attackers and their extended families to
deter others it says
but hammockhead an organization
providing free legal aid to hide his
family and the Palestinians living under
Israeli occupation says its punitive
Israeli government is taking measures
both against the Palestinian population
you know repression of the Palestinian
population and at the same time
undermining the Israeli judicial system
so whereas we would go to the Judiciary
you know for some level of protection of
human rights in this climate we are very
skeptical about how much we can expect
the high court to be intervening many
Palestinians we spoke to didn't want to
be identified for fear of being arrested
they say Israeli restrictions and poor
living conditions are giving a new
generation little hope haieri was named
after his grandfather who was stabbed to
death by a Jewish Israeli settler 25
years ago
things have changed nowadays none of us
expected this to happen youngsters are
disillusioned attacks were organized
through resistance groups in the 90s and
the 2000s now it's done by lone
individuals the escalation of Israeli
crackdowns and Collective punishment of
the whole Community is humiliating this
new Israeli government especially
policies by Ben Geer are laws of the
Jungle he acts as if they are above the
law it's the most repressive government
in Israel's history the situation that
is happening in Janine and nabulous is
all connected we're one nation living
under occupation it's no surprise
youngsters are under stress
just down the road the neighborhood's
entrance has been closed off to stop
Palestinians walking past a Jewish
cemetery there's now only one way in and
out Palestinians say they're being
squeezed in every possible way all this
as Heidi's family waits to see if their
home will be destroyed and leave them
displaced
Al Jazeera Rosa lamud in occupied East
Jerusalem